Well George, you seem to be making real progress.
Have you been tempted to uninstall Internet Explorer from anyone's computer recently?
Not recently. I mean, I used to do it all the time.
Oh God, Mom! You're not using Internet Explorer, are you?
Yes, I'm working on my blog.
George! It was about Gluten Free Gingerbread Houses.
I'm telling you mom, this browser is ancient.
The only thing that Internet Explorer is good for...
Come back over here whatever your name is.
Don't interrupt me, Nancy.
The only thing that it is good for at all - uninstalled!
The only thing it is good for at all is downloading other browsers.
Now, you've gotten over that sickness.
Yeah, because IE 9 is actually good.
Great! So now, we can finally get into your very disturbing relationship with your cat.
She's not a cat, she's a policewoman.
Her name is Officer Cupcake.
What are you writing down?